better oh well you know new parents
always want the latest and the greatest
stuff for their baby right so there is a
three-day trade show in town now with
all of the fun new baby products you'll
go crazy when you see it all it's over
at the Paris Hotel Casino inside is
Lauren negretti who has a sneak peek at
it for us Lauren good morning to you
good morning Shirley if you will you go
you'll go a little goo goo over
everything here if I can say that real
quick but yes I'm here with Melissa
Arata showing off one of the several
products here they got now Melissa with
Cybex let me tell me about what the
benefit is to parents with your products
here sure so our products are divined
with the principle of DSF design safety
and functionality this is our latest and
greatest car seat as you can see it has
you know beautiful Navy Fashions but
parenting is all about its back breaking
your child gets bigger and bigger and
you're loading that child in and out of
the car seat wait for it
no longer a problem you're going to take
your child put them in and then you can
easily place them in their stroller or
you can put them in their carry cot
ready to go this is the first Market in
the U.S and right over to and it could
go it over to the stroller now here as
well so this is compatible with all of
our strollers so as you can you know as
child gets a little bit bigger you're
running to the pharmacy you're going to
grab this put it on the stroller this is
our Koya it's part of our Platinum
Collection which is signature of Cybex
all strollers start to look alike after
a while it's like a sea of sameness but
the Koya really sexy look at the spindly
like you know legs and then it folds
into those carry-on compliance so you
can put it in the aircraft I love it for
right like you said walk right onto the
airport with that I love that definitely
a convenient and where can all this be
found you can find them at Nordstrom
Bloomingdale's Alby baby online or any
specialty retailer great thank you so
much so nice to see you great to meet
you thank you so much for waking up with
us yeah it's a great uh like you said a
little Houdini magic trick there with it
folding unfolding so we are going to be
showcasing you even more products as the
morning goes on here for now live at the
ABC Kids Expo Lauren 8 news now Lauren
my mouth is my jaws dropped I want
do-overs yeah Sherry's ready to have
kids again please because I want all
those cool Nifty strollers the swivel
thing is ingenious a simple solution
simple and it's so collapsible and fast
and sexy I love that Sherry has not been
paid for this sorry I'm excited all
right thanks Lord we'll catch up later
on